hey what's going on everybody i'm dave
rubin this is the reuben report direct
message for today
june 29 20 21 and
uh do me a favor subscribe to our
youtube channel even if you think you're
subscribed could you just double check
do me a solid
and double check see if you're
subscribed a whole bunch of you messaged
us saying that even though you're
subscribed you did not see our trump
interview from last week in your feed
i'm shocked i'm shocked and appalled
that it wasn't in your feed so
just double check and it'll take you
about a half a second
and i thank you the team thanks you and
you will be doing
your duty as a good american before we
get to all the main stories today i just
want to cover one thing
really quick 30 seconds here because
this is breaking right now so we'll
cover it more tomorrow as more info
comes in
but according to the breaking nine one
one twitter
account this is just in la public
health department reinstates indoor mask
mandate regardless of vaccination status
due to delta variant cdc officials
rethinking prevention measures even for
the vaccinated this is according to cnn
and i guess here we go again what is
old is new again something like that
like
what show me some numbers i know
delta variant we just started opening up
people started
smiling again we had a party here people
are out and about
weather has been absolutely gorgeous in
socal life is starting to get back to
normal so of course
they come back with this so okay guys
i'm a glutton for punishment i'll try to
believe you
and trust you that something's going
down here and you're just caring about
our security and our safety because
you're good people and you've proven it
over the last year you got to show me
some numbers then i want numbers i want
evidence i want to see
what this spike looks like i want to see
who it's affecting i want to see what
the symptoms are
ages comorbidities everything else no
more bs
coming from newsome or garcetti or these
ridiculous
la city council people know more of that
nonsense
and then i also want some other info
masks do they work let's not forget
lord fauci uh in his emails that were
leaked
he had a friend who asked him about
wearing masks while she was on vacation
her and her family and he basically said
they don't work
if you're just buying masks at the store
which is pretty much what we're all
doing
and then of course what this all leads
to is all right if they're going to
institute the indoor mask mandate again
i cannot believe this deja vu all over
again
here we go and and it shouldn't surprise
you i mean the thing is as
annoyed as i am right now i'm actually
not surprised because this is what these
people do
the the goal posts always move they
like power they like taking power well
i'm not going to give it to you anymore
and i'm going to keep fighting it but at
the very least you got to give me some
of those data points
that i just called to there and of
course what this really is all about
is that are they going to lock us down
again let's not forget
a few months back joe biden said if we
were good little children
that well he was reading it he doesn't
really say it he mumbled through
something
where he said if we were good little
kids then maybe we could celebrate
independence day outdoor in the backyard
with our family
well people about 350 million people all
over america have been planning on doing
just that and i'm going to be doing just
that
regardless uh let's just be very clear
about that
um so you know are the lockdowns coming
back
i mean i cannot even believe we we could
be discussing this and yet
i do believe it so here we are
we got a couple stories for you today
speaking of unbelievable
it turns out that the government is
likely spying on tucker carlson and has
been going through his text messages
uh tucker and i have texted before so
i'll drop some info
on that i want to get ahead of the story
that's number one then jake tapper who
was once
a sane journalist i believe he was the
washington correspondent for abc news at
one point
then he shifted what about seven years
ago or so to
cnn and just really kind of just lost
his mind and became a democrat operative
and i hate to say it because i think
he's probably a decent person
and the reason that jake tapper gets so
much crap from people
is because it's like we all know that
stelter is a clown and acosta's a clown
and cuomo's a
a fool like we all know that but jake
you were supposed to be the chosen one
you were supposed to go
to cnn and fix it well post trump
nobody's watching anymore his ratings
are down 75 we'll get into some numbers
on that
then number three this story is actually
kind of personal to me
joy behar on the view and you should
only watch the view
if you're highly medicated but joy behar
on the view
basically not well not basically quite
literally called my friend an
actual journalist a guy who i can say
the word journalist without going like
this
uh she called my friend andy no
a right i think a far right pundit was
the exact words a
far right pundit so we'll get into that
because i don't know any of andy's
far right positions i've had him on the
show many times he's a centrist at his
most extreme
and then finally you know we showed this
video of
bronze al gore yesterday just lying
repeatedly about trump and about
conservatives and everything else well
we found more video a whole bunch of you
guys really liked that clip
of this guy and we found more video
where he's basically calling all of us
the liars so we're gonna re-show you the
video from yesterday where he's lying
and then we're gonna show you the video
where he calls all of us liars
because as i said on fox news's
outnumbered this morning
i quote the great alexander schnitzen
often the author of the gulag
archipelago of course
and the simple quote and this is what
they do with everything
they know they're lying we know they're
lying they know we know they're lying
and they continue to lie and that's what
we all gotta fight they talk about the
big lie well they are the big liars
guys before i get to any of that i am
thrilled to welcome raise american as a
new sponsor to the show a company who
raises the bar
for premier organic grass-fed beef from
all over the country
for more than 15 years raise american
has been honing its processes
to provide lovers of beef the ultimate
eating experience from the feed to the
cattle to the steak
raise american raises the standard of
what or american
of what american organic beef ought to
be and this right here what you're
looking
at right now a little b-roll for you
that is the prime rib
that i barbecued on the grill just this
past weekend it was absolutely delicious
had a bunch of people staying here for
the big birthday weekend and everybody
was very pleased
you know raise american cattle come from
humanely treated animals reared on small
independent american farms farms run by
family farmers and ranchers adhering to
some of the strictest animal welfare and
sustainable farming protocols
healthy cattle make healthy beef and no
one knows that better than the team
at raise american raise american focuses
on sustainability which is why they work
closely with these family farms to raise
grass-fed organic cattle which spend
most of their lives grazing on pastures
in the fresh open air grazing in a way
that regenerates the
soil instead of depleting it raise
american is 100 organic 100
grass-fed 100 american so go to
raiseamerican.com right now to order and
learn more good for you good for our
planet good for america
and as i said the other day you don't
even need a code because they're only
sponsoring this show and i just love
that so if you want to
support our sponsors and support
american farmers and everything else
raiseamerican.com all right let's talk
about this really
bananas story this is tucker carlson
last night talking about how he has a
whistleblower who is telling him
that the nsa is spying on tucker and
potentially producers
of his show let's take a look yesterday
we heard from a whistleblower within the
us government
who reached out to warn us that the nsa
the national security agency
is monitoring our electronic
communications and is planning to leak
them in an attempt to take the show off
the air
now that's a shocking claim and
ordinarily we'd be skeptical of it is
illegal for the nsa to spy on american
citizens it's a crime
it's not a third world country things
like that should not happen in america
but unfortunately they do happen and in
this case they did happen
the whistleblower who was in a position
to know
repeated back to us information about a
story that we are working on
that could have only come directly from
my texts and emails
there's no other possible source for
that information
period the nsa captured that information
without our knowledge and did it for
political reasons
the biden administration is spying on us
we have confirmed that the biden
administration is spying on
us we have confirmed that okay now we
will obviously get some more information
on this we will see if the nsa
actually comments on that we'll see if
tucker's able to sit down
with the whistleblower i mean tucker is
is very good on many fronts
but you know the tucker doesn't just
throw out a bomb like that and then
just run from it right so my guess is
they're going to be talking to the
whistleblower more
they're going to be getting as much
information as possible they probably
have screenshots of things and
everything else
now i should get ahead of part of this
story which is that in full disclosure
tucker and i do text every now and again
and if the nsa
is looking at tucker carlson's text
messages there probably is a text
or two from me describing brian
stelter's potato-like shape
so i don't know if that's a crime in any
way
but that probably does exist and i just
want to put it out there
full disclosure it's out there now it's
very possible that someone
in the government let me really think
about what we're talking about here
someone from the government's going my
god have you seen these messages between
tucker and ruben
they're they're talking about stelter's
potato-like form
you know it's oh god i mean joking aside
this really is dangerous i mean this is
really dangerous stuff right the idea
that our government right
our the people that are supposed to keep
us safe that's all they're supposed to
do really the government
you know take care of the borders make
sure we're not killing each other etc
etc
that they are now using the apparatus of
the state
to spy on people who they don't like
their politics right like if you're
spying on tucker carlson if you've
basically in essence he's saying they
hacked into his
phone right because if you're going for
his text messages and his emails i mean
there's probably many
backdoor ways they can do this you don't
necessarily have to hack in like a
traditional sense like
however they're intercepting messages is
he using encrypted messaging all the
time
are they the ones that that are behind
the encrypted messaging apps i mean who
the hell knows what's going on here
the very idea though that the united
states government would be spying on
private citizens and by the way
tucker carlson is a private citizen
right i mean he's not a member of the
government he is someone that talks
about politics for a living he is
allowed to share his opinion
he is allowed to interview people he is
allowed to share his thoughts etc etc
just as
i am allowed to do that just as you were
allowed to do that and you know you
don't have to love the government and
you don't have to love the
administration
and one of the interesting things about
this is doesn't this seem like the exact
type of thing
that they would have accused trump of
doing that trump was using the
government
to spy on people and take out his
enemies and all those things except
none of that ever happened did it none
of that ever happened but
i do have a decent memory and you may
remember back
to six eight years ago remember that irs
scandal now you wouldn't know about this
irs scandal if you read the new york
times or washington post or you watch
cnn or msnbc but the irs scandal was
that the obama administration
was using the irs under a woman named
lois lerner
to go after political opponents so they
were
intentionally going after tea party
organizations and they went after many
of them
because they did not like their politics
so under a democratic president
they were going after you know let's say
right-leaning libertarian conservative
non-profits using the power of the state
the power of the irs to go after them
and now we had four years of president
trump a republican that didn't happen
and suddenly we've got a democrat again
and now we're using our spy
services basically to go after tv hosts
you see a problem here you see a problem
here and this is also why whenever i
bring up
tucker because he's so on the front end
of so much of this stuff i always make a
point of saying to you guys you know the
reason they're always
trying to cancel tucker and take out
tucker and now spy on tucker
is not because of tucker it's not
because of tucker
that man a guy who i happen to like it's
not about him it's a signal to the rest
of us it's going
we can spy on him we can get him
canceled because we'll go after his
sponsors and everything else
and if you think we can go after him
well then we can obviously go after you
so this is another one of those things
where this is where we need bravery we
need bravery not only from tucker and
his
his staff and the people at fox news
that are going to back him and they're
going to get their proper lawyers and
everything else
but we need bravery from guys like me
and people like you to stand up and say
enough is enough you cannot use the cia
the nsa et cetera et cetera to spy
on ordinary americans are we going to
allow that what kind of country are we
going to be i guess that's really what
this is about
you know we've watched a lot of things
in this country kind of falter
right a lot of things don't seem like
they're quite working right i would say
it's a
mild escalation if we're going to say
that the government is fully allowed to
spy on people because it does not like
what their politics are so obviously
there's going to be more on this story
we will find out and again if you're if
you're an nsa person and you're
potentially watching this show
everything that i said about stelter's
potato-like form
these were jokes these were not meant as
threats
and i think if you review the tape you
will see that i was quite right about
the potato thing
all right let's go from one cable news
station
that people are watching to one that
people aren't watching and of course i'm
talking
about cnn because jake tapper's show
is absolutely tanking and you know
yesterday
when i was talking about stelter i was
making the point and i've made this
several times this idea of do we have to
talk about these people anymore
and i think it could be argued either
way whether we should talk about them or
we shouldn't right because it's like
on one hand we should just ignore them
and if we just ignored them maybe they
would just go away because very few
people are watching
and on the other hand they have this
very incestuous i would say insidious
relationship
with all the websites and big tech so it
always seems that their influence is a
lot bigger than it is
so we should call them out for the
nonsense so jake tapper who really was a
decent journalist
and i suspect is probably a decent guy
but you end up working at cnn
and you're it's like they give you a
lobotomy once you're there
uh well his show the lead with jake
tapper it is just tanking in the ratings
we've got some quotes here
from fox news cnn's the lead with jake
tapper
has shed a staggering 75
of its audience since the liberal
network experienced a january spike
in viewers tapper's program averaged 2.8
million
viewers in january but settled for only
000 in the 4pm eastern time slot from
may 31st through june 23rd losing three
quarters of its audience in the process
tapper's second quarter viewership is
down 49
compared to the first quarter tapper has
also lost significant viewers among the
key news demographics of adults 25 to 54
dropping 79 of january's audience during
the first three weeks of june
in his time slot tapper's show is down
47 percent
in the second quarter compared to q1
among the category most coveted by
advertisers
in april cnn awarded tapper with an
extra hour and expanded the show from 4
to 6 p.m eastern
but the move hasn't paid off in the
ratings department for the struggling
network
the lead average only uh 799 thousand
viewers during the 5 to 6 p.m eastern
window
through june 23rd while fox news's the 5
averaged 2.6 million during that same
time slot
uh to beat tapper by a whopping 229
percent okay look i i don't want you to
get completely lost
in the numbers there and ratings this
and ratings that and the nielsen ratings
even make sense anymore who's got the
little
nielsen box in their television like
this isn't 1954.
but there's a wider issue here which is
what are people paying attention to and
why are they paying attention to it and
when are they paying attention to it so
why were rick
jake tapper's ratings really great in
january let me think for a second
guys was there something happening in
early january was there
some sort of fraudulent second
impeachment
and a whole thing where there was a guy
wearing horns in the capitol
and something something it was like an
episode of the simpsons yeah these
people
need donald trump donald trump became
god to these people he became the center
of the universe to these people
and without donald trump nobody wants to
watch
their drivel nobody wants to watch their
democrat
propaganda and tapper is now suffering
because of that
and the fact that they gave him an extra
hour and that didn't help
and the funny thing is when you know
when i in good times when when the
country is open and i go around and i
speak and i go to colleges
when i give talks and i obviously talk
about cable news a lot and
censorship and all these things cnn is
the punch line
i don't even need a joke i just say cnn
the kids start laughing
because it's so ridiculous to them so
this is really interesting and if you
wonder
why suddenly people are starting to talk
about trump again we're going to get to
bronze al gore in just a second if you
wonder why they're still talking about
trump
and why they can't let the insurrection
that nobody brought a gun
to that was over in an hour why they
can't let it go
it's because of orange man they need him
if this was broke back mountain that
would be jake gyllenhaal
saying to what's his name who is the
joker and uh heath ledger
saying a heath ledger i can't quit you i
think he said it to him who said i can't
quit you to the other who said it i
think it was jake gyllen yeah jake
gyllenhaal
said to heath ledger i wish or i wish i
could quit you or something like that
he wanted to quit him you know what i
mean it wasn't easy to be gay back in
the mountains
that back then okay and that's what
that's the relationship that these
people have
with donald trump they wish they could
quit him but they can't quit him
because they love him and they need him
and they want to sleep with him
all right let's move on uh joy behar
speaking of ridiculous people on
television there's some real themes in
the show today
joy behar and first off joy if you're
watching this
i used to love you i really did joy was
a decent
liberal she was very funny if you watch
i mean i'm not that
i would recommend anyone ever watch the
view or go back and watch old episodes
but if you remember
that first season when rosie o'donnell
was on the view this is
gosh this is back how many years ago
what year was the first year that rosie
o'donnell
was on the view this is over 10 years
ago at this point probably like 12 years
ago or so
when rosie was the was the moderator and
joy was just a panelist
i used to watch the view all the time
and elizabeth hasselbeck was on there
she was the conservative at the time
and it was just it really was a good
show it was
it was people talking about politics
that disagreed but they respected each
other it was decent
wow 2006 o'donnell replaced meredith
vieira so
geez 15 years ago was the season i'm
talking about
it really was a good show and they were
they were talking about
uh you know the obama movement which was
sort of just starting and they were
talking about
the iraq war and all of these things
that were important and relevant and
everything else okay
and then they would do a segment on like
how to clean your house or something
then i would tune out but the hot topics
thing was actually pretty good
and joy was decent and i used to live a
block or two away from joy in new york
city i used to bump into her and her
husband on the street we talk about
comedy
i've interviewed her a couple times on
my old siriusxm
show and on some red carpets and things
and she was a decent
liberal but something has happened to
the decent liberals and
almost all of them have gone completely
off the deep end and just
freaking lost their minds again because
trump
just broke these people and i would say
if you're a decent liberal who's not
insane at this point
you're a conservative in any event joy
was on the view yesterday
and listen to what she said about my
friend
and journalist true journalist who's
been on the front lines
uncovering what antifa is doing in our
cities andy no let's take a look
the banjo player from the group mumford
and sons
winston marshall announced that he's
leaving the band
after getting blowback for praising a
far right-wing pundit's book
about antifa in a post on medium
marshall claims he doesn't want his
views to bring down his bandmates
so leaving is the only way he can speak
freely
yeah i've been following this for a
while when he first tweeted about andy
now and even the way andy know is
introduced like on this show that he's a
right-wing crazy person
i don't know where that came from he's
actually a very brave journalist that i
believe is in the hospital right now
and he has been reporting the only
person that's been reporting about
antifa in portland
for the past two years and i you know
the antifa is so bad over there the
national guard was sent in to try and
help kept portland under control they
had an autonomous zone
where people were getting killed and
raped and it had to be disbanded like
he's just reporting and it's very
strange to me that he's been turned into
someone that could make
someone in mumford and sons leave the
band he his statement is really
fascinating and
i thought it was really well done he was
saying just because you're calling out
hypocrisy on the left doesn't make you a
you know right-wing extremist as well
okay so obviously well said megan mccain
right there it's nice to see someone
actually defending something close to
honesty and truth and everything else
um i don't know that andy noah is in the
hospital right now but i will tell you
this he was invited to my birthday party
this weekend and i was actually willing
to fly him out here
um but he wanted to rest up because he
does have injuries related
to some of his reporting and what antifa
is doing to him okay that is a fact that
is out of his
mouth okay the idea that joy behar would
call him a far
right wing pundit now far right wing
pundit when you say far right wing
punishment what what is that implication
the implication is racist right like
number one it's
racist it's usually homophobic now andy
happens to be gay but
i guess you could be a gay homophobe
these days if you're
if you're not a leftist um it's that you
are
against the other right your prejudice i
don't even know
it doesn't really mean anything at this
point it's just in essence what joy
behar is saying is evil right she's
saying
evil person andy no now andy noe has
been under attack
physical assault and has been violently
attacked by people
many many times joy behar doesn't seem
to care about that
now i'll give joy the benefit of the
doubt the benefit of that would be that
joy behar doesn't know what she's
talking about and she's just reading a
script
that they put in front of her right she
was obviously reading off a teleprompter
for that intro so joy i will go out of
my way here
to give you the benefit of the doubt and
perhaps you will apologize for
reading the lies that your producer put
in front of you
that will be uh what i will do for you
here joy in
in the name of the fact that you were
once a decent liberal but this is this
is absolutely disgusting now it would be
far more fair
for me to say that joy behar is a far
left lunatic she is a far lefty she
wants the government
to do absolutely everything she thinks
that everyone who is against her is a
bigot and a racist
and a homophobe and i would also argue
that at that point once you've accepted
those things you're pretty much
a lunatic okay and you can get joy to
take almost any position on anything
depending on
what trump believes so you may remember
back a few months ago i think we covered
it
when uh who is the the white supremacist
who's the leader of the alt-right
remember that guy
richard spencer remember that guy
richard spencer i can't even remember
his name because
these people are irrelevant but at one
point during the the presidential
campaign
richard spencer said he was no longer
gonna
support donald trump and joy behar
brought that up on the view
and the audience applauded so they were
applauding joy was instigating the
audience to applaud for the white
supremacists because at least the white
supremacist is against trump
these people are all completely
bananas they're a combination of like
compulsive chronic liars
and just off the rockers bananas nuts
that really is it uh but if you don't
even
believe any of that i i do want to just
say on a personal note that andy no is
one of the most
decent people that i know like this is
the most
soft-spoken um you know just
decent people i met andy know for the
first time when i was on tour
with jordan peterson we had communicated
a little bit uh over twitter
throughout the years but i met him at a
jordan peterson show
in portland right and portland was was
pretty disastrous at the time and we had
a bunch of protests outside and
everything else
and i was actually taken back about how
quiet
and soft-spoken everything it was now
i've had him on the show a bunch of
times i'm going to just throw you
just a quick 40 second clip because
actually andy had
uh subsequently invited me to an event
up at portland state
oh no you know he didn't invite me there
he was covering the event that i was
invited to
by peter bogosian and it was like it was
protested of course by
antifa and all the usual suspects and
it's like you tell me watch this just 40
second clip
and you tell me is this the far right
wing pundit you tell me andy no my
friend welcome back to the reuben report
thank you dave it's so nice to be
speaking with you again
last time we met in studio was shortly
after i was beaten
you were you were just a scrappy kid
trying to do
journalism yeah that's right dude
actually i was part of the student group
that
uh organized the event that invited you
so
just uh four years ago i was just this
student journalist uh part of the free
expression group uh
at university who was a fan of yours and
you know it's been such a um privilege
to
to not just become better friends with
you over the years but then like to
to rise up in our in our um careers and
work
because it's really linked yeah
yeah yeah kind of hitlery right joy i
mean just absolutely ridiculous if you
want to know more about
andy and and just hear some more of that
discussion we're going to link to that
in the youtube description below so you
can take a look and you decide for
yourself
i mean the simple fact is joy and and
this is if we had a media that was
decent
um that this is what they would do they
would say okay joy behar
you just accused andy noah being a far
right
wing pundit now you have to tell us some
of his
far right positions what does his
position say on immigration that would
make him
far right or his position on literally
anything that would whatever that means
to you
but it doesn't mean anything it's just a
signal
to the base bad man bad bad man
joy it's just you know it's kind of
depressing when you when you're old
enough to know
that you're the people that you used to
really respect when you when you watch
them just go off the deep end it's it's
like ah
you don't want to say anything about it
on one hand i saw the story this morning
i was like i don't feel like talking
about joy
but it's like somebody has to defend the
honor of decent people i guess that's
really what it is
so al gore i can't make a segue from
decent people to al gore so i just just
went over it
uh al gore we played this video of al
gore yesterday standing in a black room
with a
with a space horizon behind him because
he thinks he's somewhat important even
though he isn't
um he who once by the way as i said
yesterday
sold his failed tv network literally
failed tv network that no one wanted
any of the properties on the tv network
no one wanted the host no one wanted the
shows no one wanted anything
to do with it but he used his political
power as vp to get a cable channel which
is
very hard to get he created a failure of
a network then he sold it to qatar
for 500 million dollars that al gore
mr al gore i fly in private planes while
i'm telling you all how to behave
related to environment and recycling and
everything else well we played some
video of him yesterday
just blatantly lying about trump about
conservatives
about the the media just like everything
well then more video popped up today
where he's claiming that we're the liars
let's take a look at overly tanned
bizarrely orange
kind of bronze and i wonder if that's
spray-on because that's probably not
good for the
environment al gore we keep getting this
nonsense like this uh foolish
exercise to to to bring in
some cyber ninja group in arizona to
look for bamboo in the ballots there
it's it's absolutely nuts
we hear about ai standing for artificial
intelligence
they're putting another kind of ai out
artificial insanity
they're putting out messages that create
an
alternate reality and people get into
these
uh echo chambers on the internet and
it's all they hear
and they begin to believe the alternate
reality
we've got to follow the rule of reason
and honor american democracy
and acknowledge the will of the american
people they spoke loudly and clearly
oh al with your extremely bizarre color
and you're really bizarre that's cyber
ninjas
i don't like this guy i don't like him i
don't like any of these people i think
that's fairly obvious
but you see what he's trying to do there
he's trying to basically say it's not
just about trump it's basically
anyone who doesn't agree with me is
somehow he's saying you know you're a
conspiracy theorist you've gone down
this path
you've created your echo chambers as if
this guy doesn't live
in an echo chamber like it's just
endless but and oh just talk about
artificial insanity he's talking about
the artificial insanity
of the people who don't believe what he
believes now i want you i'm going to
throw you the video that we showed
yesterday
of al gore and you tell me who's
suffering from artificial insanity
i would say please do the right thing
acknowledge reality
stop hurting this country stop
undermining democracy
honor the great and honorable traditions
of the united states of america
this cannot go on the way it is now i
will
i will point out pamela that it's kind
of a sideshow
and people are turning off to it now i
really think they're beginning to
and joe biden's popularity continues to
rise
look at what he's done in controlling
the pandemic
look at what he's done in facilitating
the incredible
economic resurgence with a very strong
climate plan going overseas
and really bringing the respect for the
united states
back up again after it sunk to a
historic
low during the previous of four years
for reasons we
all understand core i had to do a lot of
scribbling
during that even though i covered this
yesterday because you're claiming that a
bunch of other people live in an
artificial reality right
so some sort of conspiracy nonsense
world how many things did you just say
that are completely nonsense
uh well first off he claimed that trump
is undermining democracy now that could
be debated related to the uh to the
election results and all that
i don't want to be kicked off youtube
just for expressing an opinion
while breathing in between words uh but
i'm fairly certain that there was a
whole bunch of people that were
screaming that trump was an illegitimate
president and something about russia
russia russia
remember that donald trump jr had lunch
with a ukrainian on the upper east side
and my god
something about that then he claims that
joe biden's popularity is rising i have
yet to see any
evidence of that i see a lot of people
that voted for biden that can't believe
how bad it is
then he claims how great biden did with
the pandemic
do you guys remember about 25 minutes
ago the delta variant is here everyone's
dying
i blame biden then he talks about the
economic resurgence
have you guys seen it i haven't seen the
what are you talking about yeah you guys
are printing an awful lot of money but i
haven't seen the economic resurgence
economic resurgence would be tons of
small businesses going back into
business and hiring
people but you guys just print money and
you keep people working from home
uh not even working from home you keep
people on unemployment not working from
home i should say
uh then he says about biden and climate
i mean it's just irrelevant to talk
about that at this point like what
what has joe biden done for the
environment yeah we've signed some
papers and we feel good about paper
i like the environment and i wrote it on
a piece of paper uh and then that
you know that other countries like us
more now that was the big one
i mean complete nonsense also they don't
respect us as much they know they can
walk all over us they know they can say
whatever they want you've seen the
videos
of the of the chinese politicians
basically mocking our secretary of state
and the series of other things does
anyone think
that the united states backs its own
word at this point does anyone think
that joe biden is in charge you saw the
videos from g7 biden fumbling around
like he's at shady pines i mean lordy
lordy
anyway al gore not a good man
my name is dave rubin and uh this
morning on the reuben report youtube
program
we posted part one of my interview with
miami mayor
francis suarez actually if you want to
see a politician that is a competent
executive
that is doing what he should do that
loves his city that wants to free people
and that wants an economy that is
booming and doesn't want to make every
decision for people and everything else
we did the interview on location uh in
miami it's a really really interesting
interview i think you'll really enjoy it
part one of that is on youtube right now
of course the full is up already
completely ad free at
reubenreport.locals.com
uh and then uh oh this friday
we're not doing a roundtable this friday
i'm giving my guys the day off uh so
that we can have a nice
uh fourth of july weekend and i hope you
guys will have a great fourth of july
weekend too but of course we'll be back
in studio tomorrow i think that's it
this was a full
dense show i think you know my feelings
about joy behar i think you know my
feelings about jake tapper i think you
know my feelings about al gore
and how you feel about them is up to you
that's it
see you tomorrow